je voudrais voir un peu les motivations
du jugement parce que c'est vrai que là
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu accès et
je regrette quand même que on n'est pas
entendu que là on avait des personnes
qui se sont exprimées pour le 6 le
suprématisme blanc ce qui est quand même
une atteinte aux valeurs républicaines
que je défendrai toute ma vie et
on est surtout sur la dégradation de
bien
bon à l'argument de dire question venus
dire qu'en fait effectivement ils
avaient comme ils étaient plus loin
n'est pas suffisant pour prendre toute
la responsabilité face à des actes aussi
graves et donc je vous cache pas que je
suis extrêmement déçue aujourd'hui dans
une période où on voit une montée du
racisme une montée des extrêmes et bien
c'est quelque chose qui m'inquiète parce
que j'espère que la société va prendre
plus la mesure de ce qui pourrait se
passer en ce moment les valeurs
républicaines elles font société et on a
besoin de se rappeler que ce respect là
il est fondamental il est nécessaire et
c'est la survie d'une société comment on
l'a construit pendant des siècles et
franchement je le répète je suis
extrêmement déçue mais on verra la
motivation du jugement pour l'instant je
l'ai pas vu